[Arabic recitation]
the chapters regarding the timings of
prayer.
Yesterday we discussed the dangers of
delaying
without any
particular reason aside from
laziness.
And the dangers in that.
And today the author
mentions something that is similar
regarding
[Arabic recitation]
he mentions two narrations regarding
the
encouragement
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam that
we make as soon as
begins as soon as its time is in. and
the dangers and his discouragement of
delaying
without any real need to do so. Now
when we discuss the
timings of prayer,
salah has a beginning time and an end
time.
Every single salah,
its end time is the following salah.
That's its very last end time except for
fud. Fudel obviously has a beginning and
end time that separates it and isolates
it. Now,
if a person were to delay their prayer
until the very last part of the time,
have they technically
technically done anything particularly
wrong? No, they haven't. They are not
incurring sin if him by doing so.
However, they are
for sure flying very close to the sun,
right? They are in the danger zone.
And when the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam was asked which which deeds are
are most beloved to Allah, he mentions
making salah at its beginning of its
time, making prayer at the beginning of
its time. soon as it comes in
and this is in keeping with a p a
person's enthusiasm to make salah.
He says he mentions two narrations. One
on the authority of
and the second on the authority of
Salahb
narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam says, "My nation
will still be upon goodness as long
he he says will still be upon goodness
or he said will be upon the
as long as they do not delay
until the stars spread across the the
sky vividly." When the stars become
vivid in the sky above
this means that we are getting very
close to
the next narration
narrates that the messenger of Allah
used to make
notice the wording used to make
this wording in
articulates habit.
He used to make
this articulates habit. Would we find
something that
is an exception? Sure, there's
exceptions because of circumstance. But
this was his habit. Meaning this is what
his sunnah is. This is what he sall.
Wasam would choose to do given the
choice that the messenger of Allah
wasallam used to make
as soon as the sun set and the dis of
the sun was no longer visible above the
horizon. Meaning if you were to look
at the western horizon
when the time for salah begins in the
prophet's time sai wasam the western
horizon would still be very bright but
the dis of the sun is is gone.
This means that he was making
at the beginning of its time. Now there
is another extreme to this right. The
other extreme is that some have read
this and read narrations this and
understood this to mean that a person
should make and right after each other
that
is right at the
so in some the for will be made as soon
as the is finished the for is made. This
is extreme. This is not the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam sunnah
because the least amount of time that
should be between any adan and this
means without need without need. If we
have some need it's okay sometimes but
to make our habit without any necessity
the least amount of time between and
should be enough time to make two you
should be able to repeat after the make
the dua after
and then make two before the is made
because people technically are not
obligated to make wuboo
and start coming to the masid until the
adan is called. Right? If you were to
begin your
trek to the masid or you were to begin
preparing yourself for salah as soon as
the adan is called, you would probably
miss a portion of salah
before you're even able to finish
making.
Therefore, the general rule
is that the least amount of time between
and should at least be enough time to
make the proper after following Adam and
two.